Arthur does it help they have someone to  talk to  [Music]  my mother always tells me to smile and  put on a happy face  she told me I had a purpose to bring  laughter and joy to the world  [Music]  is it just me  or is it getting crazier out there  though your harvies akin smile even  though it's breaking when there are  cloud in the sky  you'll get bad luck if you see sorrows  and maybe took my  [Music]  what's so funny  just reach  [Applause]  [Music]  Gotham has lost its way  what kind of coward would do something  that cold-blooded someone who hides  behind a mask  [Music]  [Applause]  I used to think that my life was a  tragedy  realize  it's a comedy  [Music]  you just  you  you